when it comes to streaming
counter-strike these days as a pro
player there's a lot more to worry about
than your average stream snipers and
aimbots there's a scamming problem in CS
streaming and it's a pretty big issue
today I'm gonna break that down for you
[Music]
if you're watching this show right now
chances are you watch twitch you go home
you sit down you pull out your laptop
and you browse twitch to see who's
streaming your favorite games what does
that means League of Legends
counter-strike fortnight or if you're me
Magic the Gathering and right at the
very top of that browsing page are the
biggest streamers and in big games that
means tens of thousands of viewers huge
communities built around individuals but
in counter-strike these days that's not
always the case because the biggest
streams aren't always who they say they
are right now if you went to
counter-strike on Twitch it might not
actually be Stewie to case streaming to
10,000 people sometimes these streams
are fakes and more specifically phishing
scams they're stolen rebroadcast of
popular streamers like Stewie 2k simple
or shroud that are literally designed to
lure you in and tricky so you click on
the stream right and you think you're
gonna be watching the I we play Counter
Strike but you're greeted with ads
disguised as giveaways that ask for your
personal information you're starting to
get the picture here they make it look
like shrouds just giving away something
new on stream he's obviously a popular
face that you trust you then click on a
banner that says giveaway and it takes
you to a baked steamed login so you
enter your account info and now your
[ __ ] they go into your account take your
skins and your cosmetics and sell them
for cash now of course this is messed up
for a bunch of reasons stolen personal
info stealing those broadcasts from the
streamers in the first place and
misleading communities that have been
built over years hell in December when
simple was literally banned on Twitch
and couldn't stream
he caught multiple accounts doing this
to him and here's an example of what one
of these scams really looks like is a
bullet okay
bu-but but it actually goes a little
deeper than that because the reality is
these accounts are really hard to track
they're constantly changing their names
and doing everything they can to mislead
viewers this whole thing it's kind of
like a constant cycle even when one of
these accounts gets caught and banned by
twitch they just start a new account and
do it again and at the heart of this
problem is really how these streams are
being advertised okay so bear with me
for a sec let's say you're one of these
scammers you upload a vada one of Shroud
streams you call yourself shrewd and you
play it while he's offline you trick the
viewers everyone thinks your shroud you
add some viewbots and quickly your
viewership jumps up to 22,000 viewers
this exact example happened on January
22nd even though Shroud literally
doesn't even stream on Twitch anymore
someone's pretending to be me and
selling skins
how do they have so many viewers that's
why I was saying like this like 5,000
viewers pretending to be you and what's
more is that those same streams are
being offered within the csgo client the
point I'm trying to make here is that if
it's popular even if it's a scam even if
it's a rebroadcast people are gonna have
it served up to them 22,000 viewers and
that's what they're gonna see at the top
of the csgo page and as you might
imagine the csgo community is not
pleased about this what it seems like
the problem here is to me at least is
there's almost no way to police this
kind of thing we all know that live
streaming is sort of the Wild West and
this is a prime example of that the most
popular streams they're gonna rise on
the twitch charts whether they're
playing for tonight
literally sleeping on stream or I guess
now trying to scam you and this whole
problem well it's not new either this is
part of a bigger problem that we've
watched unfold on Twitch over the last
year disingenuous streams like this
being served up to viewers it's been a
problem in other games for years like
dota 2 and runescape and remember when
ninja left twitch his old channel had
advertisement for other channels that
were showing porn there was a porn
account that was number one being
recommended on my channel
and I have no say in any of this stuff
so this is like this is the line this is
the straw we're trying to get the whole
channel taking out to begin with or at
least not promote other streamers and
other channels on my brand on my freakin
profile remember that graveyard that was
the artifact section on Twitch after the
game died oh yeah more porn there was
even that horrible situation back in May
in that same artifact section on Twitch
or they were rebroadcasting the New
Zealand mosque shooting to get a little
bit more information on what turned out
to be a complicated subject we spoke to
a book solo an OG runescape streamer who
has been dealing with problems like this
for a long time basically pretend to be
the official runescape stream and then
later on they started to pretend to be
distributes as well I think they
actually waited a bit before because I
think it's a bit min for some reason I
don't question the scammers would
re-upload his videos the same way I said
they were doing in csgo and they would
use click fake titles like I'm quitting
to draw viewers in it actually got so
bad that wokes had to create a not
quitting command in his chat so his
viewers knew that they'd got duped now
we haven't seen much of response from
twitch on the subject at all but you've
got to admit it's a pretty tough problem
to solve and wokes experience echoed
that exact same sentiment yeah so when
they started in person community I
contacted my manager on Twitch and sent
me to fix this but he said it's tricky
so I don't really know if channels on
fixing with twitch you definitely
understand why they'd want their service
to offer up the most popular streamers
at all times you let those big fish get
bigger and their popularity drives
viewership views are views and any of us
that spend a lot of time on the internet
we all know that but as streaming grows
you'd have to think that at some point
you want some kind of checks and
balances to combat against this kind of
thing I found this potential solution
from a Twitter user named Olivia de
grace
pretty interesting you'd have some
automated software that cross-referenced
everything that was being shown on
twitch with an archive of bad videos
even flukes himself he thinks there's
some so
Solutions but he is not hopeful that
they're gonna happen yeah well I think
to our solutions they're probably little
bit complicated though I don't know if
despite what some of you might think I
think we finally have proven that the
office behind us is real people do work
at the scoring sports it's not just call
in making all the videos and in fact are
we do not have a green screen behind us
with our boss watching TFT every day
while you guys watch these videos